はい今回もやってまいりました外れ社長の文房具コーナーで
間週1回ぐらい文豪いうことを持たせていければいいなと思っています今日は
のパイロットさんの新商品のそう bye でございますロフトで買ってきました
パーサーこちらです
スレ触れスプリンターです最初に受けた印象としてまーあれですね色のバリエーション
が何種類があるんですけどすごい
独特な色をしてるんで全部こんな感じですちょっと固めのグループですけど遊びな感じ
です
ペン先は
こんな感じです
昔あったパイロットロレックスグリップみたいな感じですね
だから200円だぞ
200円この時代に100円の車便はねちょっと安いですね
ねっくすぴりっぷの後継機版みたいなイメージがあります
閉鎖機とか先がすごい
ベックスグレープに先制
シンプルでいいです一応色のバリエーションはこうなっております
奇抜の色がおいて目立ちますねおそらくこのシャーペンの特徴は
まあ僕の前はいったと思うんですけどこのペンを振る
フリフリ機能があるんですけどプラグ役の子沿い先は新東石堤まあ基本的にはほとんど
はサーフィンな標準装備されているような状態になっているんですけれども
振るときに音が鳴るとて一つによっていない加工
パパッとことちょっととって来フってなんかぷっ.
てぷっちょうどするからもう
もう
あってるとなる人がいると思うんですけど
降ったときになろうとをかなり軽減しているとのことです
ちょっと振ってみますね
聞こえるから振ってみません
結構しないか
小さいよ
6体でリプとかをこんなことドクターグリップはこんな落とします
コミュニティがてないでこっちはこれ全然はどっちがいません
dee
天川ないか実際聞いたらわかると思うんですけど結構大人小さいです
なく静かに触れますねあんまり迷惑ならないような
フリフリ機能が付い出るシャーペットのことです強く押し込んでこうペン先が引っ込む
ことはなさそうですね
を
これはこれはねー
勉強花取るタイプだグリップ自体はそんな柔らかくないかためなんですけど細いから
すごい
フィットしますいやー書きやすいってこれ全然
いいですね非常に良いです
ブーバーし
すー
ええええええ
e 7 a